[Music]
all right so let's circle back to the
family stuff because I remember you said
the family stuff last time and the
importance of a two-parent family I was
I come my parents are still married
forty some odd years I just went back to
my childhood home in New York and for
the first time I did have I think I saw
a little more tangibly what you were
talking about to go to my parents house
to feel that it was the same place that
I grew up in the same community that I
was part of I digitally friends and some
relatives that were nearby
and it didn't feel like it connected me
to something that was important
it's sort of an ephemeral thing it's
something that's not quite tangible but
something that's important that does it
lays your roots so to speak and that you
can sort of figure out who you are from
that is that really what you're talking
about with the family but not it's not
just that there's a breadwinner but
something else something that's sort of
bigger than that that really can lay out
what a life is folks giving absolutely
it's not just a additional check as you
pointed out it's also being a role model
watching your father get up go go to
work when he doesn't feel like it
watching him live up to his
responsibilities and you know the the
three arguably biggest leaders in this
country black leaders in this country
are Jesse Jackson al Sharpton and Louis
Farrakhan and all of them had
difficulties at night for yoga all of
them had difficult if not non-existent
relationship with their own fathers
Jesse Jackson's mother was a teenager
who was impregnated by the married man
who lives next door and when Jesse
Jackson was raised in South Carolina
kids taunted him Jesse ain't got no
daddy Jesse ain't got no daddy because
that's how rare it was in those days to
be raised without a father
al Sharpton had a nice middle-class life
into his father abandoned the family and
then down to the ghetto and in the case
of Farrakhan his mom was estranged from
her husband had a boyfriend took backup
with the husband got pregnant didn't
want the boyfriend to know and tried to
abort Louis Farrakhan with a coat hanger
so all three of these men in my opinion
have deep psychological issues because
of the lack of relationship with their
own fathers and that is one of the
reasons why in my opinion they're so
angry despite the fact that things have
gotten so much better in terms of race
relations in this country so basically
they can't let go of that Tammy not to
fully psychoanalyze that they're dealing
with a personal pain that is
extremely painful for sure and they
can't let go of that pain so now they're
kind of projecting it onto the rest of
us via policy in my opinion again I'm
not a psychologist by word that's what I
would say now a lot of people have had
bad circumstances and have not been that
that's our because of my father and then
we talked about him before my father
does not know whose biological father is
the man named Elder was a man was in his
life the longest he was a alcoholic who
abused him and abused his mother
physically and my dad was literally
thrown out the housings 13 years old
by his mother's been boyfriend who sided
with with her boyfriend when he and my
dad got into a quarrel when he was 13
years old came over came home from
school and he was making too much noise
the boyfriend got mad my dad said
something to him his mother sided with
the boyfriend out of the house he goes
13 years old the Jim Crow South Athens
Georgia right at the beginning of the
Great Depression my father was never
angry though my father said to us always
meeting my two brothers and me I picked
up the cars I dealt with under the desk
that I could what did he do well he did
a series of whatever anybody would pay
him to do cleaning this cleaning that
ultimately he got a job with the Pullman
porters they were the largest private
employer of blacks in those days and he
was able to travel travel around the
country that's how we ended up in
California he came here one time with
Sonny people smiled it seemed more
friendly and after the war was over at
my dad relocated to California to try
and get a job as a cook and he was told
that he had no references which was
California's way of saying we don't hire
black people right and my dad ended up
being a janitor work two full time jobs
as a janitor save his nickels and dimes
started a little cafe near the Pico
Union area which he ran into his 80s
well in fact I wrote about this in my
last book is called dear father dear son
to live eight hours because my father
and I did not get along I thought of my
father is grouchy and an honoree and I
couldn't understand why he was so
ill-tempered until I got 25 years old we
stopped talking to each other when I was
15 we didn't speak to each other for 10
years Wow
and my dad and I sat down for what I
thought would be a 10-minute
conversation I ended up being an
eight-hour conversation and that's where
I wrote the book dear father dear son
two lives a town
yeah about this conversation do you
think that despite what you've said
about President Obama do you think that
now that he's out of office maybe he
could step into the role that you'd like
to see him in so instead of America
turning to Jesse Jackson and Farrakhan
and Sharpton maybe they can turn to you
but if not - laughs but if not - Larry
elder that may be Obama when you
disconnected from politics can actually
talk about some of those things I mean
you address it a second ago you said he
did mention the family and mention
fathers and all that so is there a
chance you think there's a chance for
that I'm not optimistic because in his
last press conference he talked about we
still have a great deal to do on race by
the way when people talk about a great
they will do on race what all they
really mean is how black people feel
about white people in vice versa they
don't care about Hispanic don't care
about Asians they really care about the
relationship between blacks and whites
and Obama has throughout his eight years
in my opinion when he could have ignored
the race card or put it in perspective
picked it up whether it's Cambridge
police or whether it's Trayvon Martin if
I had a son he looked like Trayvon
whether it's invoking Ferguson whether
it's hiring somebody like Eric Holder
was lecturing the country on race and
racism Obama I think believed that
racism remains this huge massive problem
in America despite his election and
despite his reelection and I don't and
so I don't think he's going to say the
right thing and do the right thing I
think he I think he's encouraged black
people to think of themselves as victim
as opposed to saying look at me I busted
my butt my parents uh made sure I had a
good education I didn't make bad moral
mistakes I got married before I had kids
follow my model and you'll be fine he
has not said that at all what he said is
we have real problems in this country he
embraced the black lives matter movement
I mentioned Trayvon Martin I mentioned
some of the other things in my opinion
the reason that a lot of people voted
for Obama was because they thought he
was going to do exactly what you
suggested which is to heal us put things
in perspective tell young black people
they ought not be angry when they're
pulled over by a cop all the cop is
doing is his job instead he did the
opposite so I'm not optimistic at all
that you'll play that kind of role that
you suggest yeah so the way we deman
hope I'm wrong yeah I hope you're onto I
don't know but the way we've demonized
cops as part of this I agree I mean I
see
lot of times people just screaming about
how evil cops are and they're hunting
people down all this stuff I don't know
a ton of cops but I knew some in New
York and I know a couple here I mean
generally they're trying to do good
right I mean do you have any experience
in which we have you ever been pulled
over and haha I probably been pulled
over maybe more than almost anybody you
know I got my driver's license when I
was fifteen and a half my learner's
permit and then when I was 16 I was able
to drive by myself and I probably looked
like I was 12 so I got pulled over
probably a hundred times and with the
exception of one or two instances the
encounter was brief and professional one
time a cop told me to take my head on my
ass okay that was the first time I got
pulled over by the way yeah I was
driving and it was a light behind me and
I knew I hadn't done anything anything
wrong I see me going the guy's pulled
over and screamed at me he goes why
don't you pull over and I said what I
said to you well I was I don't think I
did anything wrong and he said whenever
you see some lights behind you you pull
over get your head out of your ass and
he was right I should have had my head
up head on my ass at uh you know the
instances in which cops kill blacks has
declined 75% in the last 45 years
according to the CDC
while the instances in which cops are
cops killed whites has pretty much
flatlined and so it's going down it is
very very very rare for the cops to kill
anybody let alone an unarmed black
person of the 965 people that were
killed by the police in 2015 less than
four percent were white cops killing an
unarmed black man it is very rare by
contrast four hundred people were
injured by lightning last year but only
250 people were killed likely were
killed by police so it's very very rare
so how much it is I know you talk about
fake news and I want to get to that but
how much of this is because the media is
complicit in all this so for example
just this morning I think the Oscar
nominations were put out I haven't even
seen them yet but apparently there are
more minorities this time I guess there
are some more Latinos and Dev Patel and
and some more black people right and you
know the last couple years has been this
Oscars so white thing to me and I could
always be for myself this is like your
eye is just off the ball you're just
paying attention to the wrong thing
where it's nice to have people nominated
to put these things but they're
irrelevant to this
but what's important at what you should
be caring about is educational at right
but the media has made such an
importance out of this that it's like
it's getting the black community's eye
off what's actually important which
would be education and family Antonio's
III couldn't agree with you more I have
an actor friend I said why is this
important to you and he said because it
provides role models it enhances the
self-esteem of black people that's what
he said I say are you aware that black
boys and black girls have higher
self-esteem than white girls and white
boys this has been tested for decades
it's been the case for a long time and
there are very very few Asian actors and
actresses yet Asian Americans Japanese
Americans Chinese Americans and Korean
Americans on a per capita basis make
more money than virtually anybody else
in this country so it's utterly
irrelevant
yeah and for us to pay attention to this
and it's also not true if you look at
the last 15 years or so roughly 10
percent or so of the nominees for the
major categories have been black people
they've been a couple of years where
there's been a shutout but add it all up
and it's about parity with population
right so that's the irony it actually is
within a couple percentage but it
actually has been in IRT and and Jamie
Foxx who got an Oscar for a for a right
I said in in connection with this Oscar
so white movement he said act better be
better raise your game don't demand
don't yell don't scream get better act
better he got an Oscar and and and I
think part of the reason he said that is
because it kind of demeaned his Oscar
right because anything you're
complaining that that Oscars are so
white how do I get one I was lucky yeah
maybe just maybe I was excellent yeah so
do you think that at times visibility is
important so for example I had I've had
jackée Harry on here she was the first
black woman I think she won for Best
Supporting Actress in two to seven
around I guess it's around 1989 or so at
that time do you think that a certain
amount of your visibility may have been
more important than it is now like
because finally a black person did it
even if you don't think that the thing
in and of itself is is important I don't
think so I remember some years ago there
was an Olympic
Black's skier named Debbie Debbie Thomas
it was her last name and she was the
first black Olympian in ice skating and
she was constantly asked who are your
role models who are your role models who
inspired you and finally to me out of
out of exasperation she said I don't
need to see somebody black do something
before I think I can do it and that's
how I feel if I want to do something
what's holding me back from doing it
other than my own insecurities or
inadequacies just get up make it happen
yeah how exhausting is this conversation
to you I don't mean this literal
conversation right now but just this
thing you know so much of what you talk
about has to unfortunately be framed
around something that you don't even
think is is real you know I mean it's
something that you think should be put
behind us that actually is behind us and
yet you have to talk about a lot just on
a personal note how does that feel to it
it doesn't bother me I think there's a
lot of feeling that race and racism
remain major problems in America and I
think that that you're approaching this
with with with sincerity and and and and
and real concern I just don't think it's
that big of a deal yeah by the way I've
emailed during the cache into Vermont
who's the lead I think the quasi leader
of black lives matter he hasn't
responded but I will I will ask him
again so I'm not doing I'm not just
playing favorites and I'm just putting
that out no no no problem this is
America there there are Cubans who are
braving shark-infested waters to get
here there are people from Central
America coming up here why do people
come here why do so many people want to
come to America and it's because it is
the land of the free and the home of the
brave it is a place where you can go
from nothing to something faster than at
anytime and anywhere than in all of
human history that's why we're here and
to me again you are are almost giving
the fourth finger to all the people who
fought struggled worked hard and died
for people that sit around in 2017 and
[ __ ] moan and whine about race and
racism yeah I suspect I know your answer
to this but what do you make of all
these people that now want to look back
on history and label everyone racist
from back then you know I was at
Monticello which was Thomas Jefferson's
home Thomas Jefferson who owned slaves
was sleeping with at least one slave I
think several who they by the way at
Monticello I took the tour there's only
about a year and a half ago they fully
owned up to everything they did not I
thought it was incredible with late days
they said this man was writing the laws
to free the slaves at the same time he
was sleeping with the slaves which I
think you could probably make an
argument was rape in a certain respect
because they weren't equal right now I'm
not saying he's a rapist in the
conventional sense but I can I can see
that argument being made but what about
that concept that we're going to look
bad that what I think the left is now
trying to do is look at all of our
founding fathers I take them out of the
give our 2017 morality right to them who
is very complex lives I mean without
Thomas Jefferson the slaves do not get
freed as quickly as they did well I
think the idea of going back and
airbrushing history and looking at
history through the filter of today's
morality is pretty silly I think all a a
state can be it's just in its own time
and that's what we're trying to be and
trying to do right now
and people are right to call slavery
Americans America's original sin but
without a compromise you would have had
in America and and there was 750,000
people both sides who died in order to
free the slaves
and people don't really have an
understanding of the the scale of the
sacrifice that people made seven hundred
thousand people at a time in this
country with just 10% the size of what
it is so that's like 7.5 million people
dying in order for there to be an
outcome with slaves are freed and that's
and those are people that died not the
ones who've been injured it was a
horrific thing that that America went
through and and on the other side comes
a thirteenth and then with the 14th and
then with the 15th amendment the civil
rights movement and and all the things
that have happened since then but but
this was a country they went to war over
this proposition now what do you make of
this intersectional thing that we have
going on now and I think we saw a lot of
it at the Women's March this this past
weekend where there's a certain amount
of people that are trying to conflate
trans issues with black issues and then
Muslim issues with women's issues and
just this whole thing where you know I
talk about all the time this oppression
Olympics and now we're all they're all
tied together by this oppression
but they all have to kind of beat each
other in oppression to be the winner
this is a toxic mess huh it is it's a
it's like all the victor crack culture
where everybody has a grievance and
everybody's making demand on the
government to solve that grievance when
in fact we have far more in common than
we have apart and we ought to celebrate
our similarities and we're not doing
that
[Music]
you